Allah
[Music]
has we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah subhana
tala in the country of Norway click on
the link and donate now for the sake of
Allah subhana wa tala asalam alikum guys
so basically brother Islam and hamat had
a fight yesterday on UFC and both of
them refused to celebrate uh what was
happening to our palestin brother
sisters but Hamza say something very
interesting and I am genuinely thinking
I think his career might have come to an
end because what he said was actually
like be honest with you it was I mean it
was it was shocking it was very brave of
him to come and say that uh and let's
watch for ourselves here is what he had
to say hey guys Abu Dhabi guys you know
what's happening in the world now right
now that wasn't happen in the cage fight
this week oh see the kids dying it
doesn't matter whever in the world
Ukraine and Syria Afghanistan Palestine
USA doesn't matter when kids die it's
hard guys I love the kids I boy he's
waiting for me that back home is only
three months if he's just crying I know
how it feel and when somebody
[Applause]
dies
inah we'll be good in the world I hope
so Muslim Christian Jewish doesn't
matter please guys be together let us
live live in this world good and be let
us be happy thank you guys so guys as
you can see I mean he was outright
clearly seeing I mean give me a rifle
give me the permission and I will go and
um fight this resistance or whatever for
that matter um and Subhan Allah you can
see that people are emotional you can
see people are rightly upset you know
and if this was to happen anywhere in
the World Imagine America being taken
over by a Muslim nation and their lands
being stolen then being persecuted
mocked spat beaten jailed and all other
atrocities in that m in that scenario I
mean what would they do what would they
do you know outright there will be an
outright war on the Muslim nations an
outright War so for me to see their
emotions Subhan Allah it just shows the
care that they have and he said rightly
so towards the end as well that Jews
Muslims and Christians I mean we should
live together in peace and Islam has had
that principles in place long time ago
the Christians and the Jews have lived
lived in Muslim lands and the Jews
specifically where they were been
persecuted by the Crusaders and being
killed and massed why because they
believe that the Jews killed their God
which is Jesus so they have a deep
animosity and hatred towards them so saw
when om ruled over Jerusalem there was
no Jews he brought Jewish families to
that area so brothers and sisters in in
our show you can see how vocal he is and
W we all should hate what's happening
for the sake of Allah subhana tala and
do whatever we can with our social media
platforms with our tools whatever we
have in our hands speak up with truth
even if it's against yourself or your
king that means if my own blood my
mother or my father or my brother or my
sister or my daughter or my wife whoever
for that matter is wrong someone I
cannot be like I'm going to favor you
cuz I'm you're my blood no because
Justice is more beloved to us than
anything for that matter and this was a
reaction of hamat and Islam for that
matter insh and you can see the anger
and if you saw these videos you would be
angry why do you think the whole world
is standing up in uproar there is a
protest happening today I think maybe
hundreds of thousands if not a million
people are going to be hitting the
streets this might be bigger than the
Iraq war protest people are seeing it
and Allah has put Mercy in everyone
Muslim or non-muslim so when they see
atrocities gun towards innocent people
innocent pal inan children they are
coming and standing up and let's carry
on until this apartheid this occupied
State comes to an end inah and is
returned back to the Palestinians we are
talking about the Zionist we are not
talking about Jews we do not have any
problem with the Jewish Community or the
people Nothing in our religion tells us
to be hostile or hates Jews for that
matter that's all I'm going to say
inshah may Allah subhana bless you guys
I am in the Haram in the Caba making Dua
for our brothers and sisters inshah and
we ask Allah subhana T to show us the
end of Zion not the Jews zus I believe
the Jews should that should be a
Palestinian State ruled under Palestine
and the Jews should live in peace with
the Palestinians that they did for
hundreds of years so we want the end to
the state Israel not to the Jewish
people till next
time Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you will in be reaping a reward click
the link and donate what you can